dans notre correspondante à noyers
bonjour anne and pourquoi ça bloque côté
allemand pourquoi on refuse d'une
certaine manière pour le moment
d'exclure la russie de swift
et bien comme souvent l'allemagne est
réticente pour des raisons économiques
on le sait exclure la russie du système
swift c'est une arme à double tranchant
et c'est particulièrement vrai pour
l'allemagne
3600 entreprises allemandes sont actives
en russie pour elle les répercussions
seraient très importantes et puis vous
le savez l'allemagne importe plus de la
moitié de son gaz de russie un gaz qui
chauffe de très nombreux foyers
allemands et qui fait tourner également
l'industrie du pays l'allemagne dépend
également du charbon et dans une moindre
mesure du pétrole provenant de russie et
tout cela est achetée via le système
swift le gouvernement allemand estime
donc que cet approvisionnement en
énergie pourrait être en danger si cette
sanction est appliquée contre moscou que
la russie pourrait tout simplement coupé
aussi le robinet du gaz et du charbon en
mesure de rétorsion cela pourrait
conduire à une déstabilisation
du pays selon la ministre des affaires
étrangères anna lena bareback bref le
gouvernement allemand dit vouloir
réserver cette possible sanction pour
plus tard au cas où la situation devait
devrait encore s'aggraver ce qui est
assez difficile à entendre évidemment au
vu des événements d'ukraine merci
beaucoup à noyers correspondante france
24 à berlin